sexual assault survivors are fighting
back against a controversial law
enforcement practice which they say
helps attackers avoid justice
exceptional clearance is what it's
called it allows unsolved cases to be
closed if a victim is deemed
uncooperative or a district attorney
declines to prosecute 2017 more than 40%
of clothes rape cases nationwide were
exceptionally cleared Nicky batiste met
one survivor for our eye on America
series Nicky good morning to you what
did she tell you
Yael good morning Emily birch art was 21
years old when she says she was in a
rideshare to her college apartment when
two men abducted her and drove her to a
motel 6 she says a third man there then
raped her over 12 hours that man was
never prosecuted and more charts assault
and the case was exceptionally cleared
despite DNA evidence the man behind me
grabs my throat and I go unconscious 23
year-old Emily Borchardt's says she
pleaded to be let go the night she was
allegedly raped in in Austin Texas Motel
I just remember sitting in the corner of
the room telling them to just kill me
according to Moore chart the man gave
her cigarettes and whiskey and demanded
that she shower with him borchardt
escaped called police and had a rape kit
done her alleged attacker was on parole
after serving 20 years for murder
he denied knowing her but after DNA
linked them the man claimed the sex was
consensual Borchardt's lawyers asked us
to blur his face for her protection
the suspect was never arrested police
suggest why in this audio recording from
the precinct taking a shower with him
consuming whiskey in the shower with him
together it doesn't pick the best
picture the police act like that was
consensual when really I was trying to
prevent being assaulted again because
him talking was better than him
physically hurting me police
exceptionally cleared Borchardt's case
that's when cases can be closed if the
victim is uncooperative or a district
attorney declines to prosecute
exceptional clearances
not being used correctly Liz Donegan
now-retired
is former head of the sex crimes unit at
the Austin Police Department the
public's perception about exceptional
clearance is that the case has been
closed it's been cleared with we've held
somebody accountable which couldn't be
further from the truth
right Donegan tells CBS News she refused
to change rape cases from suspended to
exceptionally cleared she was eventually
transferred out of the unit in 2011
seven years before Borchardt's alleged
assault at any moment did you ever feel
that the authorities believed you I
think they know there's a crime
committed against me didn't don't like
to prosecute these types of cases the
office of Travis County District
Attorney Margaret Moore made the
decision not to prosecute Borchardt's
case are you ever deciding not to
prosecute because you want to keep your
record the best possible because you're
worried you may not get a conviction
no we've taken cases to trial during my
administration where we've gotten not
guilty but we believed in the case the
jury didn't while borchert's alleged
rapist walks free she's dealing with
trauma it's so terrible people can't
even hear it but I have to live with it
Moore refused to discuss Borchardt's
case because borer chart and seven other
women are suing Moore and Austin law
enforcement over how their cases were
handled an austin city spokesperson
speaking on behalf of the police
department told CBS news the city is
voluntarily undergoing a third-party
review of its training and policies
regarding sexual assault cases and emily
and the other women in this lawsuit say
they just want to be believed course
that's a very messed up system when you
hear what she's saying she wants his
face blurred because she's still
concerned for her safety and he's
walking around and he's a convicted
murderer exceptional clearance I had
never heard of that I never heard of nor
had I and it's true it's extremely
important to know about events a day in
court Nikki thank you very much